如果我们真要坦诚聊聊，想想过去在大公司或者AI出现之前，我们怎么确立领导地位呢？靠的是头衔、团队规模、职责范围。
但我要说，AI彻底把这些颠覆了。
我以前有个玩笑，总说自己像是最可有可无的人，因为我不确定自己到底在做什么，我们是不是只是推动流程前进而已？但现在完全变了。
判断你是否接近那条线的唯一方法，就是你时不时会越线。如果你从没越线，那你可能离那条线还远着呢。
大家好，欢迎收听另一期Skip播客。我是主持人Nuel Singhal，今天这期节目聚焦一个我整个夏天都在观察的有趣趋势——很多公司在问，所有这些AI投入真的值吗？
看起来挺贵的，ROI也没完全体现，还有很多花架子。所以过去几期和接下来几期，我非常想搞清楚，到底哪些公司看到了AI的价值，真正做出来了什么。
于是，我邀请了三位产品负责人来聊聊他们如何把AI引入组织。他们所在的公司都走在前沿，但还足够年轻，能拥抱新的产品管理和AI方式。
来自Midjourney的Charmaine，来自Laurel的Z，还有来自Mutiny的Henrik，我们会一起进行一场直播对话，聊聊身处未来是什么感觉，如何深思熟虑且负责任地引入产品管理。
你会听到客服人员直接部署到生产环境的故事，也会听到在公开渠道展示AI技能，让专家带动整个公司前进。
还会听到哪些激励措施有效，让销售人员对构建充满热情。但同样重要的是，你也会听到幕后的系统——如何以可扩展的方式引入AI，
如何确保每一步都有价值，如何避免表面功夫，以及最终如何让整个公司以一种几年前难以想象的速度运转。所以我很兴奋能把这些带给你。
我觉得这是一种非常实用的方式，能从一线获得那些真正在负责任地引入AI的人的真知灼见。我们稍后从赞助商那里回来后，就开始对话。
今天的赞助商Firecrawl简单说两句。如果你在用AI智能体做开发，可能也撞过同一堵墙。你的智能体需要从网上获取数据，但合适的页面要么难找，要么藏在JavaScript里，要么被登录页面挡住。Firecrawl就是一个网页
数据API让代理能够大规模地搜索、抓取并与网络交互，返回干净、结构化的数据，供实际使用。超过一百万的开发者在上面构建。它是开源的，免费开始使用。别再为数据与网络作斗争，开始
用Firecrawl为你的AI代理和应用提供动力，访问firecrawl.dev。使用代码the skip今天即可获得10K免费信用额度。就是t h e s k i p。嗨，大家早上好。欢迎来到另一期The Skip播客。我非常高兴有三位嘉宾加入我们
产品负责人夏敏、杰伊-Z和亨里克。这三位分别代表了处于不同产品管理阶段的公司，但最重要的是，他们都在重塑各自公司对于产品管理的定义。
以AI优先的方式引入产品管理。我请他们三位来的原因是，他们满脑子都是关于该做什么和不该做什么的深刻见解。如果你正坐在团队里，试图弄清楚
这个AI的东西对我来说意味着什么？我该如何转变公司文化？最佳实践是什么？哪些有效？哪些是炒作，哪些是现实？我非常惊讶于他们在前线学到的那么多经验教训。所以，呃
话不多说，直接进入今天的对谈。我先请每位嘉宾快速介绍一下自己、背景，以及他们公司的产品管理工作大致是怎样的。然后
我们会接着聊几个问题。Charmaine，要不先从你开始？
大家好，我是Charmaine Chap，目前是Midjourney的首席产品官。去年秋天加入的，所以还不到一年。之前我在Twitch做了几年产品，之后又连续在两家大厂任职。
我在Meta待了两年，又在Stripe待了两年。跟转到Midjourney相比，这两段经历都大不相同。真的是跳进了一个未知领域。Midjourney是原生AI公司，我是第一个产品岗位的人，所以
公司不仅从来没有过产品人员，而且还不信任产品岗位。如何让产品支持公司、帮助公司成长，这本身就是一段迷人的旅程，而整个过程还是
在行业背景下进行的，比如AI正在颠覆所有人，让大家都有种存在主义危机，开始怀疑在AI面前，自己的工作到底意味着什么。所以，真的是一段疯狂的旅程。
欢迎欢迎，感谢你今早从圣迭戈连线。Henrik，你在纽约这边，所以我把话筒递到东海岸吧。
当然，很高兴来到这里。大家好，我叫亨里克·伯格伦，在Mutiny公司负责产品和设计。我的整个职业生涯基本都在科技领域，最开始是一名软件工程师，
后来转做产品，也当过创始人，到现在大概有15年了。我创立过两家公司，也都成功退出了。之前我在Dropbox和JC共事过，最近几年
我一直专注于做高管和运营方面的工作。正如我提到的，我现在在Mutiny同时负责产品和设计，这是一家为市场团队提供AI代理的公司，我在那里已经工作了一段时间。现在Mutiny的样子和我刚加入时
已经大不相同了，这个我们待会再细说。我刚到的时候，公司大约有60人，产品和设计团队只有6个人，算是营销软件即服务领域里一个比较成熟的玩家，
走的是企业销售路线，最低合同额10万美元，解决的是非常痛点的问题，但使用频率不算高。最值得注意的是，公司此前构建的AI功能使用率很低，
这些功能当时只是硬加到网站个性化工具上的，而那个工具是当时的主要产品和业务。从那以后，我们经历了一场相当大的变革。
至于转化，我们稍后会详细讨论。但今天我们有两位产品经理和一位设计师。
是的，是的。我喜欢这两个故事的原因是，它们和那些成立九个月、刚融完B轮、靠黑客式开发快速找到产品市场契合点的年轻初创公司非常不同。
Midjourney和Mutiny这两家公司都有多年的历史。他们很早就找到了产品市场契合点，可以说在产品管理的很多方面，现在和过去已经大不相同了，但他们代表了...
我接触到很多公司，它们大多都是普通产品经理供职的那种。这些公司已经存在一段时间了，正在经历转型，但并没有完全被AI冲昏头脑。
那些工程师们一直把公司建到现在。这是另一条路。你知道，Jay-Z，你对我们的skip对话并不陌生。感谢你再次回来和我们一起。这次我们要换个方式，
听听你的见解。我一直想多和你聊聊，因为你的经验，你知道，显然在你来Laurel之前，但在Laurel，我认为是最好的之一
关于AI转型如何发生的那些故事。那么，请告诉我们一些你最近在忙什么。
嗯，我是Laurel的CPO。所以，首先的问题是Laurel是什么？你知道，和刚才听到的一些内容相似，Laurel也经历了一段旅程。它以前叫Time by Ping，是一个计时产品。
为律师设计的，而Ryan创始人和团队在2023年重新架构了产品，特别是结合了AI，因为当你想到在AI世界中计时到底是什么，它其实变得非常非常。
有趣。但今天Laurel所做的是记录工作的最真实形式。所以如果我们有那个数字足迹，那个记录，你可以用它做很多不同的事情。你可以自动化时间表。你基本上可以为某人创建它。你也可以。
开始理解这家公司是如何利用AI的，对吧？我认为很多人在说，去做吧，用这些工具，去做吧。而且我认为每个人在好的一年里都在那条路上，对吧？就像只是用它。然后。
现在我认为我们在这条路的第二部分，那就是实际上这相当昂贵，我们可能应该考虑一下我们在token上花的钱，以及我们是否真的需要用到最新最好的模型，还是说。
你知道，这就是对话。所以现在真的很有趣，能够通过记录你的工作开始看到，人类应该在哪里花时间，而哪里又适合我们构建工作流程，让智能体（agent）和AI来发挥作用。
这就是Laurel的一部分。我也是不到一年前加入的，所以我觉得我们三个人能在这里聊聊那段不到一年的旅程，真的很有意思。公司当时是什么样的？现在又是什么样子？
嗯，我刚才提到Laurel经历了一次转型，能够真正推动那种转型，让公司达到原来的十倍，这确实很了不起。
从传统SaaS转向真正AI原生的公司，这是一段旅程。正如Henriett所说，团队确实很精简。你知道，我过去有一大群设计师和一帮产品经理，对吧？每个人都在谈论
“铁三角”之类的，觉得必须配齐所有人才能保证产品质量。但今天，我只有五个产品经理和四个设计师，团队非常精简。而且我把每个人都视作产品建设者。所以
我们有一个概念：对于这个项目、功能或任何要成功的事情，最重要的一点是什么？有时候，最关键的是离客户最近。所以我们真的需要
派人去一线吗？我们需要一个客户专员吗？那个人会是端到端的产品建设者吗？还是说，这其实是个技术开发问题，比如我们怎么让这个系统变成一个智能代理？
我们本可以更高效地在此基础上开发和编写代码。嘿，那个计划由工程团队牵头，他们从端到端既是建设者又是负责人。所以我们真的有这种“船长”概念，而船长可以是
任何职能，产品、设计、工程，甚至超越EPD（工程、产品、设计），可能是客户成功，有时甚至是法务。所以真的很有趣，你可以开始混合搭配牵头端到端计划的人数。
因为我们都可能成为建设者，客户成功团队在合理的领域也能直接交付到生产环境，这样速度会大幅提升。我认为这才是真正的速度感，那是
今天公司经常谈论的，它不仅仅是说“好吧，我们需要用代理工具建更多东西”。更多的是关于角色和职责是什么，以及如何维护
这些系统，以便让每个人都能前进？
是的，关于最后一个问题，我从你这里听到的是，看，我们正倾向于扁平化组织。我们也在引入一个新概念，即民主化地决定谁是变革推动者。这个人的身份
可以根据工作性质而改变。但人们担心的是，如何避免踩到别人的脚？你怎么知道所做的改变是安全的，而且
不会影响到生产客户等。你如何建立足够的裁判系统和规则，以避免造成损害？
所以我认为你有两个概念，对吧？一个是我提到的“船长”——谁端到端地拥有这个任务。我认为船长需要非常明确，不仅仅是你可以开始做然后扔过
围墙。如果你作为船长，你要全程负责，比如其中的QA部分。现在，客户成功人员能像工程师那样进行QA吗？不能。所以，这就回到了
你提到的系统部分。那么，我们如何真正构建系统，以便我们能够设置护栏？我给你一个设计例子。我认为这是一个非常容易理解的例子。你可以想象一个
世界，如果任何人随意设计任何东西并直接塞进产品，你很快就会得到弗兰肯斯坦（指拼凑出来的怪物）。所以，我们不能那样做。我们做的是，我们已经大力投资于
设计系统。例如，我们相信Laurel的品牌是什么，视觉语言是什么？我们如何思考每个产品部分的感觉和外观？让我们确保
我们有组件并确保一致性，这样当有人进去用Devon构建功能时，我们在那里经常用Devon，他们基本上调用设计系统，使用
相同的组件。然后我们也会编写护栏。我们说，“嘿，在产品的这个部分，重要的是你知道这里什么能碰什么不能碰。”我用的类比是有点像
园艺。我经常对团队说，产品的有些部分就像人们正在积极灌溉、布置整个花园布局的地方。
你不会想进去种一棵随意的郁金香或蒲公英。你要等景观设计师真正完成景观设计，好吗？然后我就知道
这个花床我种郁金香，那个花床我种番茄或其他什么。所以当我们说“现在这个产品部分我们正在做全面翻修”时，我们心里就有这个模型。
因此，对于客户成功团队来说，在这里做这个、在那里做那个没有意义，因为会被覆盖或重写，或者他们不知道这个产品从愿景角度会走向何方。
但他们能做的是，我们已经真正打扫了花园。有一个修剪得很漂亮的花园，叫做我们的管理后台。同样，我们已经重新架构了它。它非常适合开发，对吧？所以人们可以进去。
即使不是技术人员，他们也可以自己写代码。他们知道使用什么开关，什么在里面，什么不在，然后他们可以在那里自由发挥。而且，这非常重要，
因为对于我们的客户来说，管理后台可能因客户而异，因为我们是企业业务。因此，客户成功经理拥有最好的上下文。当我们赋予他们权力去做出这些改变时，我们确实获得了非常好的影响。
所以，这就像花园的哪个部分正在经历大规模翻修和重新种植？花园的哪个部分实际上已经种植好了，你可以进去把东西放在合适的种植箱里？
然后我还想指出这一点。花园有些部分可能只是杂草。你会想，我不知道，有点乱。我一年没碰了。我不知道未来六个月会不会去碰，但我想要速度，对吧？所以我不想说，哦，这个杂草丛生的区域不能碰。
我们实际上有这样的口头禅：嘿，如果某个区域真的杂草丛生，
现在已经很混乱了，只要我们从测试的角度设置好正确的护栏，对吧？你不会把bug发布到生产环境。这是最后一部分，也是工程真正负责的部分，然后你就
可以放手去做了。就像如果到处都是野花，如果你决定在野花里种点什么，不管是什么，我们都不会介意的。这实际上能买到很多
好感，因为再次强调，我们的客户群体能够真正地说，我想要这种互动，然后嘿，24小时内就上线了，这买到了客户中心度和好感，
我觉得这是人们在考虑产品速度时想要的。所以这个比喻对我们帮助很大。然后就是要非常明确每个人的角色。设计负责人的角色是
这些是花园里可用的部分。这也是我的角色。设计负责人的角色是明确花园那部分的设计。然后工程师的工作是嘿，
你可以在这个区域种任何东西。这是怎么种另一个区域的方法，看在上帝的份上，别种入侵物种，因为它会占据一切，然后定义这些。
是的。我喜欢这个的是，如果几年前我们进行这次对话，我们在讨论首席产品官或产品负责人需要具备哪些技能。我认为那不会在
当任何人都可以发布到生产环境或给客户展示东西时，管理变化的规则的雷达上。现在这已经不仅仅是产品职能的期望，而是产品负责人的核心部分。我想
Charmaine，我接下来问你，当你加入Midjourney时，Jay-Z描述的那种结构，我想可能和你开始的地方差得很远，因为产品管理几乎不存在，正如你提到的，你加入了第一批产品和第一个产品经理。所以你在
更像是一种教学和展示的模式，说明产品管理的价值。我很好奇，你最初六到八个月的旅程是怎样的，来
站稳脚跟，并理解整个业务？
是的，说实话，这真的是一段非常有趣的旅程，也是很让人谦逊的旅程，对吧？如果我们真的很坦率地说，如果我们想到我们在领导力上找到自己的位置，
在过去的大公司里，或者在AI出现之前，看的是你的头衔、你的团队规模、你的职责范围。十年前的趋势是扩大你的范围、扩大你的团队，越大越好。
你拥有的越多，你越成功。但我要说的是，AI彻底颠覆了这种观念。如今，团队越精简，反而越有吸引力。团队越小，用更少的人能做更多的事，这才是关键。
所以对我来说，从那些大科技公司出来，那里以规模和人数为标准，人们也从中获得领导力，而走进一个从未有过产品部门的公司，
我其实不太清楚产品能帮上什么忙，这真的很让人谦卑。另一个重大变化是，我之前待过的每家公司都是产品驱动的。
而Midjourney显然不是产品驱动的，因为他们根本没有产品团队。我觉得他们更像是研究驱动的公司，学会在研究驱动的公司里找到自己的位置，
以及如何为这样的公司创造价值，可能是这段旅程中最让我谦卑的部分。所以我进去后，做了一次全面的评估，看看哪里缺了，我们能提供什么价值。
对于产品人来说，这意味着什么？我最终领悟到的核心就是产品判断力。如果人人都能开发，每个团队都在构建，那么你最重要的事情就是确保每个人都有判断力去做对用户真正有益的事情。
所以我们早期做的一件事，就是每周甚至每周多次，与真实用户进行用户研究访谈，并让团队成员参与其中。
因为，让一个在公司工作很久的人亲眼看到新用户在第一次使用产品时如何挣扎，是提醒他们产品有多么难用的最好方式。而且我认为这立刻...
这让它变得弥足珍贵。基本上我们所有的工程师都开始加入了，还有一些设计师也参与了，这对每个人来说都是大开眼界，于是就成了一个起点：我们如何帮助
在公司里培养每个人的产品判断力，这样我们就能共同学习如何为用户打造最好的产品。我特别喜欢的是，我们一半的工作已经变成了，你知道，既要改变又要建立产品
文化，但我觉得在AI的世界里，这就大不一样了。我转过来问问亨里克，也许你可以花点时间讲讲Mutiny的商业层面，以及公司最初是怎么
运作的，现在又是怎么样的。你知道，Charmaine描述的是如何建立早期的成功，让产品管理不仅显得吸引人，还能把我们在做的事情和它的使用方式串联起来。
在你这个案例中，你需要在战略转变上取得早期胜利，并真正改造你们的产品构建方式。所以，我很想更深入地听听这个故事。让我先回到JC刚才说的关于...
关于心态和文化，尤其是对过度转向的恐惧，因为我认为当我们像现在这样是个小团队、小公司时，我们更倾向于从心态而非治理的角度来处理问题。而且我认为...
当你试图推行变革时，总会有很多恐惧，比如'我是不是做得太多了'或'我是不是走得太远了'。我认为当你朝着某个目标努力时，这种情况总是存在的，因为...
你有一条无形的线，你想尽可能地靠近它。那么，怎么才能最好地试探出那条线的位置呢？我的看法是，唯一能知道自己离那条线很接近的方法，就是你偶尔会跨过它。
所以，如果你从未跨过那条线，那可能意味着你离它比你想的更远。因此，我认为更重要的是在团队内部建立韧性，让大家明白...
在一些事情上做得过头没关系，只要我们能回头看看发生了什么，从中吸取教训，然后未来做得更好。那有没有什么过头的例子？比如，是指用光了token，还是...
嗯，或者把生产系统搞崩溃了？
对，我觉得实际上更像是比如你让所有人都能直接发布到生产环境。是的，自然你会看到一些东西发布到生产后，你会想'哎，我们本该在上线前...
再仔细检查一下的'。也许功能没实现，也许没用到设计系统中应该用的部分。所以感觉有点像是科学怪人拼凑出来的。有些东西你得接受...
并随机应变，而不是在我们这种环境中设置一些非常复杂的流程，比如每段代码都要有人审查。所以这就像...
你懂的，一个平衡，但如果你们是大型企业，那情况就非常不同了，而不是像Mutiny现在这种PLG模式。
是的。你描述的这个有点像一种士气策略，这有点有趣。我从你这里听到的是，看，我们想通过这个转变来提升士气。我知道你们在让员工...
回到办公室方面做了一些改变。你们也在思考不同的产品策略，而且我觉得一路上你们在如何激励员工方面考虑得很周到。我听到的一部分是...
你不是用规则来激励他们，而是用赋能。你知道，'我会在你后面收拾残局'，而不是'别靠近玻璃'。这是其中的一部分。多跟我讲讲士气是如何...
转变的，然后我会问你们两个，你们是如何推动一个AI优先、AI前进的愉快士气，考虑到我们都在以惊人的速度工作，以及随之而来的一切。
我觉得当我们决定打造一个全新的产品时，关键是让团队里的每个人都感觉到我们在朝着正确的方向前进，哪怕那些事情可能非常非常微小。所以，一个...
我经常举的例子是，只要有人在产品里做了高价值操作之类的，我们就会有一个所有员工都能访问的Slack频道，它会出现一个提示音，...
不仅仅是升级或人们给我们更多钱，还有比如他们第一次尝试新功能，或者设置了一些复杂的自动化，然后就是叮叮叮，人们会想'哦哇'...
这个东西在本质上和我们以前那个SaaS工具真的很不一样，那个工具的使用频率更低。而且我觉得AI的魔力之一就是人们倾向于更频繁地使用它...
但他们也会用通俗易懂的语言告诉你，他们想通过产品达到什么目的。所以，就不太需要像以前那样，通过会话回放和产品分析来拼凑出...
人们到底在做什么。你实际上可以直接看到纯文本描述，然后如果代理在某些方面做得不好，你就有完整的背景信息了解客户的理想输出是什么，然后你就可以...
立即尝试去解决这个问题，然后马上联系客户。实际上，我们大多数客户，至少是较大的付费团队，都和我们有共享的Slack频道。所以我们可以立即跟进...
告诉他们我们已经解决了问题，他们应该再试一次，这次我们会有更好的输出。所以，就是这样，你知道，精益团队可能名声不好，但它们的酷之处在于，你也会...
让他们更接近客户，我认为这非常激励人心。
是的。你知道，Charmaine，你也有一些经验，我觉得是在Midjourney，这些实验在多大程度上是公开的还是私密的。
是的，所以我想说的是，我们为推动AI转型所做的最关键的事情就是，我们是一家原生的AI公司，对吧？但即使如此，在完全采用AI原生工作方式方面仍然存在阻力，而不仅仅是构建原生AI工具给其他用户使用。
对我们来说，最重要的事情就是公开进行这项工作，这就是带来巨大差异的地方。比如，我们的杀手锏是构建了一个内部代理，
它连接到我们所有的工具，包括收入数据、所有内部沟通的历史记录，这非常关键。然后我们有一个公共频道，一个内部公共频道，每个人都在那里
与这个代理互动。最棒的是，这不仅迫使你思考如何与它互动，还能帮助你和其他人互相学习，了解如何与它互动，
所以，例如，如果我问代理：“嘿，你能给我关于过去六周用户bug报告的数据吗？”然后某个了解这个话题的人可能会
插话说：“实际上，你可能出现了幻觉。你能检查一下这个数据点吗？”或者你可能会使用错误的数据点，应该看那个数据点。这样基本上让我们能够
群体思维，从AI那里得到正确答案。一方面，这减少了幻觉，或者更快地纠正幻觉。另一方面，这让我们互相学习如何与这个代理互动，这样
我们都能学得更快，代理也会变得更聪明、更准确。如果你想想，如果我单独私聊这个代理，问一些问题，我可能不知道它是否在幻觉，
因为我在公司还不到一年，它可能会告诉我一些超过一年的事情。只有资深员工才能发现这个问题。而且，如果我收到一个幻觉，然后去找人讨论，
他们却说：“等等，这是错的。”那真是浪费时间。所以最好直接在公共频道里做。每个人互相学习，每个人都能更快地发现错误，
然后大家也看到它能带来的价值，这样怀疑者突然会说，哦，好吧，我确实从这能得到很多价值，我能找到方法让我的时间花得值，而不是浪费，
而且你能更快达到那个点。是的，Jay-Z，你对于如何从流程角度进行许多日常转型有非常新颖的看法，你知道，而且
你在节目里说过几次这个话题，但我总觉得，在招什么样的人、怎么看待那些真正能帮我们改造流程的专家方面，你总是领先大家一两年。
你决定让Sasha加入，我记得你在节目里聊过几次。你能不能谈谈你的思路，比如你是怎么把这些专家带进公司来做这些转型工作的？
你找的是什么样的人，你当时看重的技能是什么？
嗯，具体来说，我们设立了一个叫“AI运营”的部门。你可以把它想成是现代版的商业运营专家，对吧？以前这类角色通常是通才和忍者，公司需要什么就做什么。
但通常那是受限于你能做什么而定的。那时候更多是策略和研究，然后给出建议，差不多像一个内部咨询团队。但现在，那个概念完全变了。
回到“人人都是创造者”这个理念，AI运营现在就是真正去做东西的。所以我们不再叫商业运营，而是AI运营。那我找什么样的人呢？我们基本上找的是……
真正充满好奇心和求知欲的人。原因在于，你把他们和职能负责人搭配起来，这种组合非常重要。职能负责人，比如销售负责人、客户成功负责人、市场负责人，他们
非常清楚自己要达成的业务目标，但他们不太可能真的有闲工夫去摆弄每一个新出的模型或AI工具，这真的
很难，对吧？你一天只有那么多时间。顺便说一句，有些工具你必须用得足够多，才能找到感觉。然后有时候突然就到了一个临界点，你会觉得，"哇，这已经跨越了鸿沟，真的很有用。"但你需要有足够多的精力和时间投入实验，而职能负责人很可能做不到，因为他们还要
招聘、管理结果，等等等等。所以基于这个洞察，我们想，如果我们把这些渴望成功、有抱负的新毕业生，和这些职能负责人配对会怎么样？你看，我在斯坦福和耶鲁教书，他们就是
很棒的人，比如做过咨询的人，有通才思维，但充满强烈好奇心的人。所以我们真正看重的是，你有没有在玩AI？我会让人分享屏幕，我
会让人展示他们做过的东西。你可以很客观、很快速地筛选出这样的人。把这些人和那些负责人配对，意味着他们真的能AI化整个职能部门，因为我发现很多
人其实不知道怎么用AI，所以这种配对能推动AI在部门里的落地。
有时候，团队里就是有那么一个人特别会玩，而其他人则远远落后。所以，组建一个专门的AI运营团队来推动工具采纳，真的是意义重大。
而且，也许我可以简要分享我发现的三大杠杆。第一是激励机制，回到Henrik的观点，我们搞了个黑客松，我基本上就是让团队里的产品负责人去面对整个GTM团队。
其中一个项目经理心想，天哪，我这是在打开什么大门啊？但他们还是去教大家怎么构建并上线功能到生产环境。所以，这位项目经理就担起了责任，即使心里发怵，也要打开这扇门。
然后，我们设立了奖励机制：第一个成功把功能部署到生产环境的人，当然要通过一些检查，就能拿到现金奖励。
于是，你能看到，大家就像在TSA安检队伍里等着，或者登机前，都迫不及待地打开笔记本电脑，想赶紧提交自己的代码、合并请求，因为他们都想成为第一个。
然后呢，我们就建了一个频道，叫“问问评审”，大家可以进去求助。这再次呼应了Charmaine的观点，是一个公开的频道。我们用的工具叫Dust。
我们构建了很多智能体，但我鼓励人们不要直接去用Dust的界面，而是把它深度集成到Slack里，再配合Anthropic的标签功能。你会发现，你得把AI放到人们所在的地方，人们就在聊天软件里，对吧？
人们可能在邮件里，可能在各种软件里。我们大量使用Slack，所以我们就让Dust能在Slack里被调用。记忆功能真的很重要。
我们想了个超简单的方法，用表情符号快速操作，比如一个文件柜，或者直接说“添加到记忆”。因为总会有幻觉，有不准的地方。
我们的文档可能过时了，所以，如果你问一个问题，它会给出回答，然后标注所有合适的人来补充上下文，我们再把新内容存进文件柜，这样就形成了一个良性循环，确保上下文总是最新、最相关的。
这些点点滴滴就是激励，或者说小贴士就是激励。建立一个公共系统，就像Charmaine说的，确保上下文能不断以最优雅的方式更新，这样你读到的，你的智能体也能知道。
最后，我想谈谈这个想法：从下到上、从上到下地构建一个系统。
回到我之前说的职能负责人和AI运营专员。职能负责人对结果有自上而下的视角，他们相信时间应该被重新分配。所以我有一个非常强烈的
观点，产品经理应该少花时间写文档，多花时间与客户在一起，构建产品并展示反馈循环，而不是写那些容易丢失信息的文档。所以我做了的是，我
实际上已经能够把我的想法编成所谓的“时间分类法”，然后从下往上，我们在Laurel有幸能部署我们的桌面代理，它能捕捉到所有的时间。所以
我们可以比较，嘿，Jay-Z认为应该更多时间花在云代码上，更多时间花在开发上，少花时间在写Google文档或Notion上。我们就能开始追踪这些，
现在不是每个人都能做到这种追踪，但你仍然可以很好地了解时间分配的大致情况，甚至看看使用了哪些技能。比如，在任何
给定的组织里，会有三个人创建一大堆技能，然后其他人得搞清楚该采用哪些。而且我觉得我们其实有一个问题，就是技能太多，每个人都在
创建自己的版本。我认为大多数公司需要做的是花时间说，好吧，这是我的工作分类法，这是我的工作本体论，我想把时间花在这里，而不是那里。
现在没有一个完美的测量系统，有一个会更好，但如果没有，你可以直接说，我有没有将技能映射到我期望员工做的每件事上，然后我可以看看他们
使用技能的次数。就这样，简单得很。所以如果你真的系统化地思考变革管理和工具采用，你就能得到很多你想要的东西，
通过激励和其他因素，让它成为组织持续能做的事情。也许现在是时候问一个来自观众的问题了，就是作为CPO，你如何处理AI速度带来的大脑过热和
上下文过载？对你们三位来说，我的问题恰好相反。你们描述了这么多上下文、这么多赋能、这么多想法和工具，这些在两年前都还不存在。
这显然会导致信息过载。所以我很有兴趣听听你们如何谈论节奏，如何跟上节奏，无论是作为
领导者还是团队，如何在这样的世界里保持清醒？我想这也联系到聊天里Gab Rubinsk的问题，就是说随着速度加快，我们该如何...
作为CPO，帮助我们不致于被淹没，也不至于让终端用户体验碎片化。我觉得我们正在尝试的方法是分布式产品管理这种理念。也就是说，不再把产品看作
客户、用户和团队其他成员之间的守门人，好像我们整合一切，写出漂亮的文档，确保每个人清楚该做什么。而是有点像
把产品领导者的两大主要职责分开。第一是自下而上的理解和背景，跟客户紧密合作，交付他们想要和需要的东西。第二是
更自上而下的动作，确保我们朝着未来前进，并且确保我们构建的一切都融合成一个连贯的故事。我一直在努力
把注意力转移到更多自上而下的部分，确保大家协同一致，然后赋能工程师、设计师和市场人员，帮助他们把客户的各种请求
转化成我们要在产品中做的事情，有时候甚至直接在产品里发布那些东西。而你可以借助一些有用的技能做到这一点。我觉得Charmaine，你有一些
关于如何让人们擅长用户访谈和制作对组织有帮助的产物的好建议。这些东西现在可以被编码，不必
成为每个做这件事的人的个体技能，而是我们可以将其具体化，让AI真正协助做得更好。这几乎像是尝试在整个组织中
分发品味和更好的产品判断力，而不是只把它局限在产品管理上。这就是我们有效使用的一个技巧。
是的，我来补充一下，分享一个我们构建的具体技能例子。我提到过，我们希望每个人做用户研究访谈，并且尽量让流程简单。所以
如果我期望每个人每周至少做一到三次访谈，假设访谈30分钟，你怎么让其余流程尽可能短，对吧？所以我们用了AI工具，比如
记录并转写整个访谈，然后一结束，我们有一个接入那个工具的Claude技能，你可以提示它说：“嘿，给我这段对话的关键结论，给出他们关于产品体验的三个高光
和三个低谷，然后把那些片段做成视频，这样人们能观看并感受到那种切肤之痛或喜悦时刻。比如，给两个痛苦例子和两个
愉悦例子，做成两分钟剪辑。”然后真的在15分钟内，我快速检查一下，拿到摘要和剪辑，做点小调整，就可以发到公共频道给所有人看。所以
整个用户研究周期，从访谈开始到把洞察分享给全公司，可以只需45分钟，而这个技能成为全公司共享的技能。每个人都在用同一个
技能。我觉得这很关键——你不希望人们各自构建自己的技能，那样会变成AI世界的杂草。所以你想保持花园
修剪整齐干净，每个人都用同一个技能，避免到处都是稀释。
是的，这在很多问题中都出现了。很多人都在问，技能、版本和评估在爆炸式增长。你描述的赋能方式，是流程吗？是
第三方工具吗？还是一套大家遵守的规则，来保持理智，确保大家都在同一版本？你怎么保持组织有序？
你知道，我们会有不同的答案。我简单说，因为Midjourney很小，对吧？我们不到100人。我的产品团队现在三个人，两个PM，一个产品数据人员。所以我们很小，所以
对我们来说，我们不用担心版本和流程。我们更容易保持同步，比如“这是我用的技能，这是它的用途。”所以在Midjourney，确实是我在创建规范，
像是“这些是规范，我们如何使用这些规范，或者我们每天工作时如何遵循这些规范。”我们保持简单。但可以想象，像你们这样更大的公司，可能
需要更多实际流程来组织。是的，我们有一个公司操作系统，基本上我们上传一个文件夹。很简单，一个文件夹。我们一开始在GitHub上，因为起初更多是
工程和产品在用，但现在我们放到了Google Drive，因为最终，尽管我想让每个人都像工程师一样上手，我们雇了很多销售。再说，我们是企业
公司，让所有人同时转变思维模式很难。所以现在在Google Drive里。你打开它，里面有个文件夹，包含所有公司联系人。所以我要做的是把所有愿景
文档、战略文档、定价和包装文档，所有作为事实来源的东西，我都转换成MD文件并上传，这样解析起来就很容易。然后每个职能部门都有一个文件夹，法务、
市场、产品、销售等等。在每个文件夹里，我们基本上列出了我们认为该团队应该做的事情，对吧？所以我再以产品为例，我认为你基本上在做
客户探索，对吧？实际上是与客户接触。我认为你实际上在支持销售周期，这对企业公司来说非常真实。我认为你在构建东西，这很有趣
因为以前你会说：“哦，产品生命周期，你写规格，然后不，你是在构建。”而我反思的是，我认为人们应该做的事情反映在我的本体论或技能文件中。所以
我基本上说，我们有这些期望你做的事情，对吧？我们期望你实际上能交付代码。我们期望你作为产品经理，能够将小型功能端到端地完成，甚至大型
功能，至少承担其中一部分，尽可能端到端地完成。所以这就在一个非常简单的文件夹中编纂起来，这个文件夹在Google Drive里，里面包含了所有技能，并且给你提供了
上下文。它给出了你应该如何使用Laurel这个工具集。所以，如果我雇一个新人，他们不再需要从头发现和编写自己的技能。如果有人想要一个直观的
逐步演示，我想大概一天前，Akos Gupta在增长播客上分享了我的屏幕共享。所以如果你真的想看看这个文件夹结构是什么样的，你放了什么内容，如何
上传到云端，人们可以去观看。但实际上这真的很简单。现在最难的部分是让它真正地持续进化、保持常新，并且真正反映你的想法，因为事情
变化太快了，今天的东西和我们应该使用的工具集，一个月后就会改变，对吧？所以那是最难的部分。所以，初版是容易的，任何人都可以在明天为他们的团队做到，
然后真正需要深思熟虑的是如何保持上下文的流动，这才是更难的部分。
>> 还有一系列关于第三方与第一方工具的问题，这些工具可能是人们自己构建的或购买的。比如，Jay-Z，你提到了Dusk，提到了Devon，显然还有Slack和云端工具的利用。
代码。我很好奇，对你们三位来说，你们的工作、大部分工具、项目管理和企业大脑等等，这些都是你们自己从LLM或工程师那里构建的吗？
还是说有一些第三方工具真的让生活更方便，你们会推荐？
我的意思是，对我们来说，这是混合的，对吧？比如我们知道有些工具可以直接买，比我们自己做的更好，我们就会买。就像我提到的，比如录屏和共享屏幕的工具。
可以转录，还能帮你生成剪辑片段。市面上有不少工具能做得很好，像那些巨头或同行，随便挑一个用就好。但另一方面，我们内部的
代理，用来处理机密信息，需要访问我们所有的数据和代码库，这个我们就打算自己内部搞定。所以我们在建设这个。如果想要从这些工具里榨出最大价值，你还得做这笔投资，因为
外部连接器能做的终究有限。所以我想说的是，比如用户研究访谈，那种能把它跟内部数据直接连起来的感觉，那就是关键时刻。
我们的内部代理简直太神奇了。比如我在用户调研电话中，用户遇到了一个相对简单但很烦人的bug，我可以直接告诉代理：“嘿，能修一下这个bug吗？”
它发生在这样的界面上，预期行为应该是这样的。”等到用户调研电话结束，代理已经创建了一个PR，团队的工程师可以直接审查并部署，bug就修好了。
这样一来，积压任务的概念几乎不存在了，因为我们一边发现问题一边实时修复。那些小问题几乎立刻处理妥帖，马上就能用。我觉得这就是那种
神奇之处——我在电话里，电话还没结束，用户发现的bug已经修好了。这简直不可思议，对吧？但真的超赞超有趣。
那么，关于过去几个月我们听到的“token最大化”这个趋势呢？就是那种排行榜，目的是让人们兴奋地去充分利用AI。我很好奇你们
对这在你们公司是否有用有什么看法。你们试验过这个吗？或者是不是正在试图摆脱它？
我觉得那种做法可能只是短暂的风潮，当时大家追逐token最大化。首先，它太贵了。而且如果你只是随意消耗token，却不清楚它带来的投资回报是什么，
这就好比衡量代码行数或者你提交的PR数量，而这些对于衡量你为客户创造的价值或进展来说，都是很糟糕的指标。所以我觉得它们是一类问题。
而且我觉得，AI虽然提高了天花板，但并没有提高地板。所以，我们更倾向于投资于能提高地板的工具，比如让每个人都能接触到更多上下文和信息。
就像JC你刚才提到的那些，比如打破协作的壁垒。我们是个重度使用Cursor的公司，所以我们会把Cursor和Slack集成起来。
一旦客户报告了bug，任何人都可以进去说：“嘿，Cursor，你能看看这个bug是怎么回事吗？如果可修复的话，你能直接修一下吗？”
然后，它就会生成一个PR，交给某个工程师审查。一旦审查通过并发布，Cursor就会在讨论串里更新：“嘿，这个已经合并了，客户已经可以使用了。”这是一个很好的闭环，
不仅对我们内部，对我们的产品用户也是如此。我想听听你的看法，鉴于你们在那些最前沿、最具变革性的公司工作，我想请你们退一步，
谈谈对下一批人才，比如那些刚入行的产品经理，有什么职业建议。你们都在之前的公司工作过，也和很多产品经理合作过。
我好奇的是，你们能否给出简明扼要的建议，给那些曾在你们之前公司工作过的同事，我们就姑且称他们为产品经理吧，让他们更聚焦一点。你们会建议那些产品经理怎么做，
才能不落伍，才能有资格进入像你们这样的公司？对于那些对产品经理这个职能消亡感到焦虑，或者觉得AI会抢走我们所有工作，想知道是否该转行的人，你们有什么建议？
我很想听听你们对这个大问题的看法，因为你们身在其中，而且你们一直在不断推动别人向前。
我觉得我认识的很多人，他们现在都比以往任何时候都更兴奋，因为过去很长一段时间，你经常会撞墙，比如“哦，我得把这个交给设计师”或“交给工程师”。
我以前常开玩笑说，我是最可有可无的人，因为我觉得我到底做了什么？我们到底做了什么？无非就是推动流程而已。但现在完全变了，
这太让人兴奋了，对吧？你不再是“哦，工程师其实不向我汇报”或“设计师也不向我汇报”，我只能靠影响力。我们以前经常对初级产品经理说，
你要善用你的影响力。但我想说，不，你要善用你的构建能力。你要利用你比任何人都更懂业务、比任何人都更懂客户的优势。这两个的交集，就是
产品业务背景和客户背景，而现在你终于有能力去构建产品了，这太让人兴奋了。顺便说一句，这就是我的职业建议：如果你是那种人，
并且倾向于构建，同时保持那两个不变的东西，也就是业务背景和用户背景，那你会比以往任何时候都更受欢迎。因为现在你不再需要配五个或六个工程师，
你可以一个人就是一个团队，甚至都不能叫团队了，就是单人团队，对吧？所以这超级让人兴奋。对于那些对管理特别热衷的人，我觉得
这也是一种心态上的转变。你会想：“不，你终于可以管理一群Agent了，以前你得等第三名员工入职，才能壮大你的PM帝国。”但我想说：“你知道吗？你可以随时启动无限多的
实习生，而且通过正确的上下文，你可以让这些实习生快速成长为更有经验的产品经理。”这太棒了，对吧？所以我觉得，如果你真正去拆解那些当初吸引你进入产品领域的东西，
比如对构建的热爱、对业务的热爱、为客户创造价值的热情，那对某些人来说，实际上的团队管理、指导、塑造战略愿景，
所有这些，只要你保持开放的心态，其实都更容易实现。同时，我觉得对刚毕业的学生来说，这也是巨大的机会。我以前常跟我的斯坦福学生说：
“最快获得PM工作的方法就是你已经有这个头衔了。”所以这有点两难。那我的建议就是，你去某个地方，先加入其他职能，创造很多价值，深入了解客户，
然后再转向产品，我觉得我们很多人都是这么做的，对吧？所以以前是这么建议，但现在我会说，你可以去做AI运营、新业务运营，你可以去做部署
策略师，你可以现场为客户构建解决方案。以前你可能只是在处理工单，那是最无聊的工作。现在你说：“我听说这个了，我拿起我的乐高积木，就给你搭了个东西。”
这不是很棒吗？这就是产品的精髓。所以我觉得，如果你重新审视这一切，这对新毕业生是巨大的福音，对热爱构建的人也是巨大的福音。当然，这也有点吓人。
对于那些还没完成思维转变、好奇心不足、也没花时间动手实践的人来说，你问这个问题很久了，我最后想说的是，怎么才能
跟上这一切呢？我觉得这有点像我们有个核心价值观叫“猎豹速度”，就是你真的要全力冲刺，然后得休息，因为你不可能一直这样。
所以会有连续十个周末，我都在搭建、玩各种最新最棒的工具。我会和儿子们坐在一起，说咱们一起造点东西吧，这就是我们学习的方式。
然后某个时刻你觉得自己累坏了，需要休个三周的假，重置一下。我得花时间好好内化哪些有用、哪些没用，写写日记，想清楚
下一步的跨越式变化是什么。而且，你看，工具本身也会这样，它们先是挺好用的，然后来个大的跳跃式更新，对吧？所以你也想让自己的深度专注模式
和猎豹冲刺模式，和工具的这种跳跃式发展同步。我觉得这就是我保持理智的建议。
我也快速分享两点。嗯，所以我觉得，从战术上讲，我在Stripe或Meta这种大厂工作时，日常就是早上7点到下午5点开会，会议都是30分钟
一场，整天都在切换上下文。现在我每天只有20%到30%的时间在开会，剩下的时间都在动手构建。这正是JZ说的，现在能边学边用这些工具真的很兴奋。
如果这让你激动，那就该跳进这个转变里，对吧？那会让它变得超棒。但如果这让你不感兴趣，Nikil，你提过
你可以在大公司主导AI转型，用到跨部门协作和影响力这些技能，把它们带进来。所以拥抱AI的方式可以多样，取决于什么让你个人感到兴奋。
嗯，这是第一点。第二点是关于真正享受AI意味着什么，它对你意味着什么，你怎么才能对它感到兴奋？我觉得这确实能驱动你用AI做什么、怎么合作。
但回到怎么避免超载的问题，当我们都在工作时……
以前全靠手动，我们不得不极其严格地排优先级，因为你没时间自己做完所有事。现在有了AI，同时做很多事变得太容易了，但你反而更得狠下心来
用另一种方式去排优先级，不然你会被淹没，开始注意那些垃圾信息而不是真正有价值的东西。所以这是一种不同的优先级排序，因为更容易得到产出和
要审阅的东西，所以这感觉就像是一种思维上的转变。
我觉得这是人们重新开始、重新学习的好时机。我认为工程领域在这点上真是走在前头，你看那些头衔很大、管理很大组织的CTO们，回去做独立贡献者，
在团队里不带任何下属。所以我觉得如果你愿意放下一些对华丽头衔、大组织或对很多人影响力的控制，那你就有机会参与到
这段旅程中来，而且说实话我们还处在第一局，我觉得现在做出这种转变的人，将来在5到10年内会成为绝对最强的领导者。
可能快进几年后，我们还在谈论这种所谓的变革，引入所有这些新的工作方式。有没有可能几年后，我们会更多地回归到
产品管理历史上一直以来的做法？意思是，既然现在有了这些AI工具，公司能实现产品市场契合，而且人员更精简，那么复杂性就在于如何组织、如何管理，
然后我们开始增加产品经理，再增加管理这些产品经理的领导者。我们是不是处在一个钟摆摆回去的暂时时刻，但本质上只是时间问题，它最终会找到中间平衡位置，还是说
产品管理的根基已经变了，我们过去的大部分工作方式永远消失了？
我觉得两者都有点。我认为我们的角色确实在演变，但我真心相信我们处在一个非常独特的时期，会稳定下来，我们的一些职责会回到所谓的
正常状态。我不知道产品管理是否曾经正常过，但至少是回到更接近过去的样子，但有些事情会永远改变。
是的，我知道说两者都有是个回避问题的答案，但我真的认为就是这样。比如我们作为产品经理的工作方式在根本性地改变，因为AI的兴起，因为我们现在能做什么，能构建多少东西，还有
我拥有那份自主权和能动性。但我觉得，本质上，产品要做的核心事情没变，对吧？我们还是为了用户而创造，为了公司战略而构建。我们一起协作，去探索
什么才是未来最好的方向。这些都不会改变。改变的只是我们的做事方式，因为有了AI。然后，在协调方面也发生了变化，对吧？过去我们完全没有协调，现在
我们得学会找到一个合适的度，尤其是在这个对流程很敏感的环境里，去找到那个平衡点，对吧？我们从一个极端——毫无协调——现在得往回拉一拉，
找到最健康的协作方式，既不会拖慢我们的脚步，又能让我们自由地构建。我觉得产品经理永远不会再回到那种管理大团队、管理很多人的状态了。有趣的是，
原则反而比以前更重要了。我在斯坦福教产品基础课教了十年了。我们的课程从不改变，因为核心永远不变。比如，在理解问题之前，不要急着跳到解决方案；
你在为谁打造？是否清晰明确？你搞清楚怎么赚钱、怎么获取价值了吗？这些本质的东西永远都不会变。但现在变了的是，
你不再管理人了，你管理的是AI代理。你也不会把时间都花在官僚流程上，而是真正去动手创造。我觉得这些改变已经是不可逆的，而且是往
更好的方向。所以归根结底，产品经理的角色就两件事：你必须要理解业务和客户。那就是你的工作，就是那份理解。顺便说一句，产品管理的根源
实际上可以追溯到宝洁和市场营销。那就是产品管理的源头。后来我到了惠普和谷歌，我们还可以上一堂历史课，但本质上就是这些。这就是永远不会
改变的核心。最后，我认为未来的方向是，你是一个协调者。如果你只是记住：我连接商业和用户，那是我工作的核心，然后我负责统筹协作，那是我份内的事。天哪，我为什么要去
协调50个人？那也太低效了。就是这样，这就是产品的未来。如果我们拥抱这个方向，我们会玩得很开心的。
这真是一个结束今天节目的好方式。感谢三位今天来参加我们的节目。我很感谢这场对话，我觉得这些见解非常棒。我希望我们以后有机会再聊，看看一年后有什么变化。
像Jay-Z那样，你刚才说了这些话。现在还是真的吗？
我可以回顾一下。是的，你们每个人当时都说了些什么。我们可以做个小小的评估。总之，再次感谢你们今天早上跟我一起度过这个周五，我期待下次再聊。
[音乐]